[موسيقى]
هذه المدينه العريقه التي انشات في القرن
السابع الميلادي والتي استمدت جل ثقافتها
من الممالك الاسلاميه القديمه يرى الزائر
في الوهله الاولى ان هناك حلقه وصل غريبه
بينها وبين الثقافه العربيه والاسلاميه
على عمرانها وهوياتها بسبب تعاقب ممالك
اسلاميه وعربيه عده
فالبيت الهرري يشكل الجزء الاكثر خصوصيه
في هذه المدينه
فتصاميم منازل هرر خارجيا وداخليا تخضع
للعادات المستمده من الدين الاسلامي بينما
تمزج صفاتها المعماريه بين الثقافه
العربيه والبيئه المحليه ولكل عنصر هنا
اهميته الرمزيه والعمليه
مستمده من الدين الاسلامي وجميع الادوات
المعلقه هنا على الجدران لها دلالات
اجتماعيه ويتم استخدامها في مختلف
المناسبات مثل الاعراس والعزاء وغيرهما
ولكل عنصر هنا اهميته الرسميه والعمليه
غير بعيد من هنا زرنا سوق هرر الشعبي
فاسواق المدينه لا يلجا سكانها للتبضع
فحسب بل كل حسب حاجته فهذا ساع للرزق وهذا
مستريح بعد عناء طويل وغيرهم الناس هنا
وسطاء يفصلون احلامهم لمستقبل واعد
كتراثهم الغني فالكل ياخذ حاجته من السوق
حسب رغبته
ومن اشهر الاسواق هنا سوق القات حيث تشتهر
المدينه بهذه النبته ورغم ان القات في
بلدان اخرى يجرم متعاطيه لكن القات هنا في
هرر يعد سلعه استراتيجيه تمثل احدى دعامات
الاقتصاد الاثيوبي وهو رفيق جلساتهم
وتزدهر اسواق القات قبيل الظهيره الى غروب
الشمس وهي فتره تناوله من قبل سكان
المدينه